I'm scared for you to have my phone who
do you think I am like know who you are
she is married and I'm single I think
Jake's gonna know don't you think I mean
you guys text me or not yeah like what
do you guys text each other I'm a
straight girl
hailer is a lesbian probably get some
like messages on hinge and tinder and
Bumble I can't think of a better friend
than a friend that helps you get laid
what
[Laughter]
oh man I'm gonna change your life I want
to change your life we are on our one
I've already matched with three ladies I
think 99% of the techs have had some
sort of emoji and that is making people
believe I'm Sarah
I've probably told her husband that I
love him about five times today Jenni is
officially trying to ruin my life I just
got on my facebook on my laptop Jenni
checked in the gas station thinking of
growing my hat collection the only
solution here is to fight fire with fire
while I was at the gym Taylor went a
little overboard
you asked my Facebook friends for anti
diarrhea medication how is that okay her
own husband does not know no one caught
no one caught on there's probably gonna
be a lot of messages unhinge
and bum ball a little bit of tinder I am
so efficient that last night I had a
dude ready to come over immediately
you're pretty fine eggplant my goal was
to get Jake to ask Morgan out on a nice
date oh I like that goal I didn't
accomplish my goal I found some good
matches for you and I hope you keep
talking to them so you're welcome I hope
you continue that I'm unmatching
everyone you match when you with
I wouldn't do it again no we would not
do this again I guess we both care like
what people think about us a little too
much yeah I don't want this ever again
did you really set me up on a date yes
100%
Oh drinks on Saturday night it's double
date that's so awkward you go on double
dates